I was shocked a lot of people don't know
that Kevin Neal and of course they know
he was on Saturday Night Live but what
they don't realize is you at one point
auditioned like five times for the TV
show Cheers when they were first
starting it and that you were very close
to being the Ted Danson role on Cheers
you were going to be Sam alone right
that's right five auditions five
auditions what year was that do you
remember I was probably about 25 26 so
maybe a decade ago yeah and that would
have been a [ __ ] unbelievable I mean
you're talking about that would have
been great I mean you know sometimes I I
sit back and think how would my life
have been different right and I wouldn't
have wanted that because I'm happy where
I am right now yeah but but it cheers
would have meant multi-millions of
dollars not that you didn't make a great
living but multi-millions of dollars
probably even bigger kind of career in
terms of film and stuff I mean Ted
Danson became a house he dances around
and does whatever he wants to do right I
never thought about it that much you're
right now
a lot of regret did you
let dancing do and do that role and say
well yeah I love that show yeah every
every time I watched it I thought that
could have been me but seriously when
you when you are that close to getting a
role in Show Business
it's like that's a big job and then when
you saw it on TV were you like that
[ __ ] guy isn't even that good in it I
am 10 times better were you bitter no I
wasn't bitter I was very young at the
time and and they you know after a week
goes by after my last audition or call
back two weeks go by finally they call
my age and they said we're looking at
some people that are older for the role
she's only 26 at the time you know and
originally the character was a bartender
and he an ex-football player instead of
the baseball player and I was the next
football player and I was an
ex-bartender from the East Coast did you
audition for Mr Jim Burrows the Jimmy
Burroughs was in the room and the
Charles brothers because these guys are
all Geniuses right yeah and did you ever
call up Jim Burrows and say listen Jim
uh why didn't I get the role did you
ever talk to him about it no I you know
five auditions to guy major and in the
last audition that the Charles Brothers
I remember Karen let's say this they
look at each other and say we're not
getting any closer than this and I
walked out of there thinking man this is
my God this is easy this business yeah I
made it but um but it didn't happen when
you saw the successive cheers you must
have been uh floored by this am I
correct I'm fascinated by this when you
hear the gradual thing that had happened
it wasn't like successful right away
like a lot of shows when you hear the
cheers song does it make you cry
I was also I got six callbacks for
friends is that true uh no oh and I got
seven to
play Batman
Michael Keaton got it
foreign